welcome back okay so we're talking about
system identification with full state
measurements for control and what I want
to tell you about now is essentially how
to use this modern Koopman operator
framework so Koopman Koopman with
control
so the Koopman operator framework
essentially says that if I have a rich
enough set of output measurements so
maybe this is even bigger than just my
full state X maybe I augment this with
non-linear measurements of my system x
squared X cubed sine of X you know
arctangent of X whatever if I have a
rich enough set of measurements then I
can embed my nonlinear dynamics into a
linear framework which is great because
anytime I tell you that I can take a
nonlinear system and make it look linear
you should be thinking well I can do
optimal linear control using simple
one-line MATLAB commands I can do lqr
calm and filtering things like that okay
so that's kind of the promise of this
Koopman with control is that I can take
strongly nonlinear dynamics and make
them look linear if I find the right
measurements Y of my system okay and
then I can do any number of things in
the control front I can do linear
control I can do model predictive
control once I have that system model
okay so I'm going to tell you a few
different flavors of Koopman with
control the one of the the things I like
to do is think about eigenfunctions so
let's think about what an eigenfunction
of the cutemon operator looks like the
idea here is what we're first gonna do
is we're gonna characterize the unforced
system with no input with u equals zero
and we're gonna find that there are
these eigenfunctions fee of x so these
are special measurements you can think
of these are really really good
measurements of your system that you can
take fee of X so that DDT of fee is
purely linear it's lambda of fee of X
okay and you know we'll talk about this
in another another lecture series where
essentially there are data driven
methods to discover these good
measurements coordinates fee of X but
let's for now assume that we have some
of these coordinates so a good example
is if I have a conservative system then
V of X could be the Hamiltonian the
total conserved energy and then D DT of
the Hamiltonian is 0 times the
Hamiltonian it doesn't change in time
because it's conserved so any conserved
quantity is a Koopman eigenfunction with
lambda equals 0 for example and we're
going to assume that we had some
dynamical system X dot equals f of X
plus B u now I've made this I've split
the system so that I have some
non-linear unforced dynamics and then I
had this additive linear control you
could do this in the more general case
where you have a full-blown nonlinear
system but I think this is easier to
understand how Koopmans control works in
this case so I've got X dot equals f of
X plus bu and now what I can do is I can
chain rule this part of my DDT of fee of
X and what I end up getting is DDT fee
equals the gradient of fee grad fee and
that's gradient with respect to X dotted
into my time derivative X dot dot it so
it's grad fee times D DT of X that's
just the chain rule and if I do that I
get grad fee dotted into this right-hand
side into f of X plus B U but remember
if I just took my unforced dynamics then
DDT of fee would equal grad fee dot f of
X and this would equal lambda fee so I
can take this part and replace it with
lamda fee and I get D DT of e equals
lambda fee plus grad fee dotted with B
times u ok so essentially this is my my
control system or sorry my state
dynamics fee dot equals lambda fee this
is purely linear
in the state where now the state is fee
and now this is my plus control okay and
so this is essentially this is called a
state dependent state dependent
actuation because now this grad fee dot
B this is a function of X because grad
fee is a function of X and when I dotted
into B it's a function of X but
essentially what that means is just that
my new B vector is a function of state
space ok so I have actual linear
dynamics I still have linear dynamics in
my in my eigen function coordinates but
now the actuation it affects that eigen
function differently depending on what X
is and so this is work done by Orica
Kaiser so Kaiser Nathan cuts and myself
so Kaiser at all this is a 20-17
archive paper by Orica Nathan and myself
so you can read more about the details
but essentially what she showed is that
if you can identify these eigen
functions these Koopman eigen functions
fee you can do control directly in these
eigen function coordinates using this
equation here and what's known as a
state dependent riccati equation so
state dependent riccati and i never know
how to spell riccati equation and if you
recall the riccati equation is what we
used in linear quadratic regulator x'
and calman filters and so essentially
this is just a minor modification of the
lqr control if you have this state
dependent actuation B so that's what
Orica showed that for lots and lots of
systems if you can find these fee using
data kind of data-driven regression to
find these good coordinates you can do
control directly in these good
coordinates okay and and this is
actually quite useful
because in many systems of interest like
like I said these might be Hamiltonian
systems or any system with a conserved
quantity you can essentially design an
optimal control law to steer that
conserved
so you know we often think about things
in terms of the state space so if I have
a pendulum on a cart I'm thinking about
trying to stabilize it by making theta
and theta dot equal to zero for example
but what you might also consider is that
that system has a total energy and maybe
what I want to do is I want to increase
the energy up to the vertical position
and then stabilize that so sometimes
these eigenfunction coordinates like
total energy or conserve angular
momentum can actually be a better
coordinate system to write your control
law in than the original state space and
you can get optimal non-linear
controllers using basic modifications of
the standard lqr riccati equation
methods okay so that's what what Erika
showed very powerful method and that's
one of these these kind of new methods
where we take system ID using Koopman
and we modify it to take into account
this actuation and control this plus p
bu other people in the community have
taken a different path so instead of
doing control directly in eigenfunctions
what a lot of people do is essentially
they so kind of this alternative route
is I could take a big big measurement
vector Y so this is even bigger than my
state maybe it has non-linear
measurements of my state and I could do
YK plus 1 equals some big Koopman
operator times YK plus some big B
operator times UK and so essentially
what you can do is run that DMD with
control algorithm on this Augmented
measurement vector and that's called
extended DMD so it would be extended DMD
if I didn't have control when I add
control it's called extended DMD with
control e DMDC and this is work done by
Matt Williams and Clancy Raleigh and
others to essentially get these system
models directly from data for this K and
this B and then you can use this either
for linear control or for model
predictive control so Mia on kurta and
Igor message recently wrote a paper
essentially doing this EDM D with
control on these big measurement vectors
Y and then using those models directly
for model predictive control which was
also quite effective okay so those are
two broad categories of ways that you
can interpret Koopman with control one
of them is to essentially build a model
on all of your Augmented measurements
this Big K model and then do dynamic
mode decomposition with control to
identify that from data and use model
predictive control or you can
essentially try to discover these
eigenfunctions of the Koopman operator
directly I probably should have
mentioned that this fee is an
eigenfunction of this Koopman operator
so k fee equals lambda fee so these are
directly eigenfunctions of this Koopman
operator and then instead of controlling
all of these directions and Y I can hone
in on just the eigenfunctions of
interest that I want to control like
total angular momentum total energy and
then you can do that using this state
dependent riccati equation okay thank
you